hello and welcome everybody to my
presentation
entitled the big four heavy metals in
cannabis
sample preparation and analysis via
icpms
you might have come across cannabis in a
grocery store
in a dispenser anywhere else so as of
today i would say
cannabis is literally everywhere you can
see it in in food
used in food used in sweets such as
gummies or chocolate
in several kinds of beverages but also
in drugs
cosmetics and personal care products
all of these uses make it of course
necessarily
necessary to test cannabis for for their
content especially for content that
might be harmful to people
and what's inside cannabis that's a
question you might ask
first of all um it's the kind of
cannabinoids
all of us know these they're relevant
because they are
responsible for the psychoactivity of
cannabis especially if the thc content
is 0.3
or above whereas you would talk about
hemp in case of a low thc content
and we have got the terpenes inside
which are responsible for
a so-called entourage effect at least
that's something
that is under discussion we have
pesticide science
which might stem from the process of
growing
residual solvents from an extraction
process for example if you go for a high
cbd
oil formulation then you would use
solvents to extract
cannabis heavy metals might also stem
from the production
of the growing process and we also have
mycotoxins which
might be generated by mold in case of
improper storage of hemp
or cannabis
cannabis we need to talk a little bit
about anatomy and that
why do i want to talk about this the
reason is quite simple
um cannabis tends to accumulate
heavy metals in its plant parts and
the accumulation of heavy metals depends
on the plant part and
it differs from heavy metal to heavy
metal
this is a small drawing of cannabis
quite old image and what you can see
here are different plant parts
that's the leaves that's for example so
the butt including
the flowers and we got the seeds
and what is missing is the root and all
of these plant parts
accumulate heavy metals and that that
for that reason it's also
being used for the remediation of soil
um that's an intended process but it can
also happen unintendedly and
therefore you need to test your cannabis
for heavy metals
when i talk about heavy metals i mainly
talk about the big four heavy metals
the big four are acetic cadmium mercury
and lead and uh what we set up here is
an icpms analysis of these big four
heavy metals
on the right hand side you can see four
images showing a typical
hemp bud in that case it's it's cannabis
that is
purchased from a grocery store in
germany
this cannabis is sold as tea so you can
make t out
of it and uh the first set of
experiments is focusing on
the analysis of such an entire bud
this is the varieties antiqua there are
different others
and we in total were analyzing three
varieties red varieties can also be
called as strains or some some
also called some subs call them
subspecies
in the second set of experiments we
segregated this
bud into the leaves seeds and also
into the stems the reason for that is
quite obvious when you look at the
products that you produce from cannabis
some only you make use of the seeds for
example hemp oil
so it doesn't make sense to analyze the
entire plant but you
need to focus on the seeds only that's
why we did the analysis of these for
these three compounds
this is the icpms workflow that we
applied for the analysis of cannabis
it's a four-step process starting with a
sample homogenization normally that's
a grinding process manual or
using a machine second step is the
standardization and calibration and that
process
difficult different chemicals come into
play for example indium that we use as
an internal standard
in that case it's recommended to use a
single element icpms standard that is
traceable
we use certipur or tracert reference
materials that are available from
millipro sigma under the trade name of
superco we also prepare calibration
curves and
in order to compensate for matrix matrix
effects
we use a standard edition approach and
for this approach we apply certified
reference
materials with which contain
the big four elements and specific
concentrations which
correlate to the state limits of
different u.s states
after this preparation of the sample or
and the standards
we start the sample digestion in that uh
situation
we use superpower or ultrapoor nitric
acid and hydrogen peroxide
and those are those are combined with
the sample in the previous step and then
digestion takes place at approximately
300 degrees c
um using a microwave and under elevated
pressure and after that
subsequent icpms analysis takes place
what i'd like to do is to focus a little
bit on sample homogenization i said we
do a grinding process
and there are different options to to
perform this process one
very simple option that you might not
have come across so far is to use a
rolling pin
in that case the sample is put into a
ziploc bag
stored in in the freezer at -20 degrees
c and then you can
can crush the sample quite easily
another option that many of you will
will know is the so-called mortar and
pestle approach
where you apply a mortar and pestle to
chop the sample and more elaborated
systems are knife mills or cryo ball
molds
uh shown in the right on the right hand
of the image
there are four of course some
differences between these uh
methods first of all the feed quantity
so
the feed quantity is quite high when you
go with the rolling pillar approach and
it goes down to very
small sample amounts of maybe a gram
when you apply cryomel in contrast
rolling pin can can
work with samples in the range of 5 to
10 grams
the temperature is minus 20 degrees c
for the mortar and pestle and rolling
pin approach whereas
uh when you apply a knife or a cryo wall
or a bomb
then you can cool during the milling
process
in that case with liquid nitrogen at
minus 20 degrees c
which is an advantage um because um
high temperatures can cause
decomposition
of cannabinoids um
normally it's a decarboxylation which of
course then leads to a change in the
sample composition
um in in addition some of the terpenes
are volatile and so you can change the
composition of your sample if you
increase the sample temperature during
the milling process
the efficiency of these different
methods is is
strongly different it's not very good
for rolling pin and mortar and vessel
approach and becomes better when going
to the right hand side of this table
best would be the cry ball mill and
down down below here you can see sample
images that result after a milling
process of
about five minutes rolling pin and the
mortar and pestle that's quite
homogeneous when you look at the images
um the knife mill is better and the best
performance with particles of 100 micron
or below will be obtained when applying
the ball mill
so my recommendation in that case would
be to go with a knife mill at least if
you
have such a system in the lab do a pre
grinding process with this mill and then
transfer the sample to the cryo wall
mill
for final grinding
what you can see here are the results
for different
metals in that case all the form metals
are listed
uh calibration data is quite nice very
linear
regression coefficient is is close to
one in that case
this is the data for the cannabis
variety of vanola
it looks identical for the other variety
so
it's not not displayed here
now let me come to the results of
milling techniques
it's a comparison of these techniques
from left to right you can see the
rolling pin
approach then the mortar and pestle this
is the cutting mill
and this is the bone milk cryobomber
hemp variety is antiqua and what you can
see is that the results are
quite nicely comparable with almost no
cadmium abundant in the samples no
arsenic and
mercury was detected the only heavy
metal that is
at least available to some content or
was analyzed as some content is
is led for for all the four milling
techniques and you can nicely see that
they
provide quite quite similar results um
for your information the limit of
detection for all the metals is 0.1
micrograms
per gram and um it was
we were in that case working quite uh
close to the yellow d
on the right hand side you can see the
felina variety of cannabis
it's a quite similar result we only
found
arsenic in one sample using the rolling
pin
and for the others only
only lead was detected now when you look
at the result for the mortar and pestle
approach um
the lead content is quite high so it's
it's uh
one microgram per gram um
that is that doubles the value for the
santika
variety and the reason for that most
likely lies in an improper sample
homogenization as i said before
the plant parts accumulate heavy metals
to a different con
content and if you in one case for
example
um analyze an inhomogeneous sample which
contains plant parts that accumulate a
lot of
lead and this would cause these false
results so
in that case you would need to do better
homogenization
as as was done here or you need to
re-analyze your sample
this is not listed anywhere but i made a
comment here the recovery rate
ranges rates are quite nice for all the
elements
plus minus 10 percent
a second set of experiments as i
explained before is the comparison of
different plant parts doing the very
same experiment the only difference is
that these plant parts were not
ground so no normal milking took place
that was not necessarily necessary
because we handpicked the
different pieces stems seeds and the
leaves and we did two experiments each
and the only metal that was detected in
any of the samples was
in that case lead recovery range was
better even better as compared to the
previous samples
96 to 103 percent and um
what what is quite astonishing and what
is also in line with literature results
is the
low lead content of the seeds so that is
known to the literature and
we found the very same uh situation here
what is a bit sad is the fact that we
work with
food so as i mentioned before all the
samples that we used here
are meant meant to be used
to prepare tea so we didn't expect them
to
contain large amounts of heavy metals so
for a better comparison
it would might be nice to have real uh
samples that
were used for soil remediation
might be an option for our next set of
experiments
last but not least a little summary for
you i showed you that we
established an icpms workflow for the
analysis of the big four heavy metals
in cannabis in that case cannabis sativa
plant material
the homogenization was reproducible in
most of the cases except for this one
experiment using the water and pastel
approach
the digestion protocol was specifically
adapted to
the needs of cannabis as it is a quite
smeary
material we adapted the
digestion protocol using highly pure
acids and hydrogen peroxide and
last but not least something that we use
in that approach was the standard
version
approach to analyze the heavy metal
content simply because we wanted to
attribute for any matrix effects that
that we might observe
but not east and this is the final slide
i would like to
present if you need any further
information about
about the sigma aldrich milipor sigma
cannabis activities then i'd ask you to
visit this landing page it combines not
only the work that we
we've done on heavy metal analysis but
also all the other compounds that
play a role in cannabis analysis so the
cannabinoids terpenes
also the the mycotoxins pesticides and
so on
with that i'd like to finish my
presentation
and i'm happy to take any questions
thank you
hi everybody my name is kathy stennerson
and i
am an analytical science liaison with
milpor sigma
and today what i'm going to demonstrate
for you is how to use a technique called
solid phase micro extraction to sample
terpenes from hemp flower
so first what is solid phase micro
extraction
well for short we call it spme and what
it is is it is the heart of it is a
coated
fiber device like you see here
that contains a either a polymeric
coating or a particle type coating
and this coating extracts analytes from
samples
either through immersion directly into
the sample or holding it all
in the headspace over the sample and
then after
extraction is complete the device is
taken over
and injected into a gc inlet just like a
syringe
and the thermal energy of the inlet then
absorbs the analytes off and you can do
your chromatography
so it's a really easy technique to do
doesn't require
any solvent and the best part is these
fibers are reusable
so it is very inexpensive it's not like
spe will once you use the cartridge you
throw it away
okay so the heart of the device are the
fibers the spme fibers
and i've got three different types here
and by types i mean that they're coated
with different
materials it can be a polymeric coating
or a particle coating
now when you get when you buy spme
fibers to know which kind you have of
course it'll be written on the box
but once you take them out of the box
they should have different colored
hubs like here i've got red black for
carboxyn red for pdms
and then blue for dye vinyl benzene and
that denotes what kind of coating you
have
now for today i'm not going to get into
a big discussion of what kind of coating
to choose for what because we don't have
enough time for that but uh for what
we're going to do for sampling terpenes
out of the headspace over
hemp i'm going to use something called a
carboxyn fiber
okay this is a very retentive fiber and
it's very good for very volatile
analytes
so i'm going to install it in my spme
holder which i have disassembled here
so the first step
is to thread it onto the plunger so the
plunger's got a
female threaded fitting and i've got a
male threaded fitting on the end of the
fiber so i depress the plunger
to bring that female fitting out
thread my fiber on the end
pull the plunger back up i'm going to
put this nut
on the bottom next
just hand tight is fine and then
this plastic depth gauge
okay i've now got the assembly
all installed in the holder and then to
expose the fiber i just push down on
that plunger
and you can see the carbon fiber which
is black
exposed out of the needle so our next
step then is going to be to get our
fiber
ready to use so we're going to condition
it to clean it off
okay so i've been conditioning my
carboxy and fiber i installed in the
holder
for about 45 minutes now and that like i
said earlier that is to clean the fiber
off and get it ready so that we can
sample with it
so at this point i've got it in a hot gc
inlet that's what i'm using to condition
the fiber and my inlet i've set to 300
degrees centigrade
i have flow going through it that's very
important you want to have flow going
over the fiber while you're conditioning
it and i've exposed the fiber by pushing
down on the plunger
now i'm going to take it out of the
inlet and one thing to always remember
when you're doing manual spme
retract the fiber back into the needle
before you take it out of the inlet
otherwise you're going to destroy the
fiber
so i've just done that by pulling up on
the plunger
and now i can safely pull it out of the
inlet
so at this point then i'm going to go
over and set up my sample and i'm going
to
get it ready for headspace sampling
all right so i've conditioned the spme
fiber that we're going to use
and now i'm going to actually do an
extraction now what i did
before you were all here with me was
i took about 115 milligrams of this hemp
that i have here this ground hemp and i
put it into this vial
this is a four mil vial with a
a septa cap so that's a cap with a hole
in it
with a nice thick septum that's a teflon
lined
so that way um when the terpenes start
to come off of the hemp they'll be
contained in here and they won't leak
out and we'll be able to sample them
and then the next step after weighing my
hemp into the vial was i put it on this
heated block and i have this block at 40
degrees centigrade
and i let it sit for 10 minutes i'm
giving the terpenes
time to volatilize out of the
out of the leaves flower material and to
enter into this empty space which we
call the headspace over the sample
so now i'm going to actually expose the
fiber to that headspace
and the terpenes are going to be
extracted by the coating on the fiber by
the carboxyl coating
so to do a manual extraction is pretty
easy
i've got this nice setup which is
commercially available that holds the
spme holder quite nicely so the first
step is you want to
you want to twist
the top part of your holder and make
what we call the needle part
very very small the idea is is that you
don't want to be
putting a long needle down through that
septum because your your chances of
bending it would be fairly good
so now i've made it very short so i'm
going to open my holder
and put it in and then at this point
it's directly over the hole in the top
of the
vial so i'm going to twist on
the silver part on the top and what's
that going to do is it's going to cause
that needle to come down
and it's going to go right through the
septum it's going to puncture the septum
and you'll hear a popping sound that
happens you might not hear that
with all the lab noise but if you were
up close to it you would
so at this point the needle's coming
down
and it just went through the top of the
septum so i give it a couple more twists
and now i'm going to press the top of
the plunger and expose the fiber
it's down inside the vial i twisted it
into the notch to hold it in place
and now i'm going to let that extraction
go
for about 10 minutes and then we're
going to dissolve it into our gcms
all right so the extraction time is up
and it's right we're ready to uh go
ahead and take the
fiber out of the sample and absorb it in
the gcms
so we're going to retract the fiber back
inside the protective needle
so i'm right now the plunger is down so
i'm going to
bring it back up and open up my holder
so i can pull it out and just take it
right out the top and then
we just walk over and we're going to
repeat the process but into a gc inlet
all right so i'm over at the gcms system
now that i'm going to use for the
analysis so i got the fiber that we just
exposed to the sample and i'm going to
set there's a gauge here we call it a
depth gauge and what i'm going to do is
twist this big
black plastic piece until i have my
needle at the proper depth for the type
of gc
i'm using now this is an agilent gc and
we recommend
setting the depth gauge at three the
reason being is that when i expose the
fiber down in the inlet it's going to be
in the hottest part of the inlet so
you'll get the most efficient absorption
so next step is just to inject it just
like a needle
into my inlet and i'm going to push the
plunger down and expose that fiber
so i'm injecting it here into my inlet
push down on the plunger
now it's inside the inlet and i hit
start so now my analysis is
is going to proceed just like it would
with a regular
syringe injection okay so
uh right now the analysis is running and
i just wanted to show you real time
what's going on and the first sets of
peaks are starting to come off
uh from our hemp sample that we did spme
on and there's a rather big one now that
threw everything off scale so what i'm
going to do now on the software is i'm
going to go down
and take a snapshot what's going on here
and i can see
a chromatogram real time so this great
big peak right here
just came off so i'm going to take a
spectrum of it this is a single quad
gcms i'm running it in full scan mode so
i can get full spectrum here
got a nice spectrum so i'm going to
library search that
and it's telling me it's beta myrsine so
that's my first big terpene that i'm
seeing come off of this
sample so we'll let you join up again
when we get some more peaks
all right so now we've got another
cluster of terpenes that are eluding
and a rather large one as you can see
here so i'm going to do the same thing
again that i did before i'm going to
take a a
picture real time so there's our first
two big terpenes that we saw
the first one we saw was a mere scene
the second guy if we do a search on that
uh take spectrum do a search that one
it's saying
is limonene so i bet you would expect to
find something like that now this big
terpene here
this one actually if you take spectrum
looks like it's probably pure it doesn't
not cold loading peaks but let's take a
search of that
and that's caryofulin which is um pretty
commonly found
so we're getting really nice terpene
profile as you can see
and the the sample preparation was
minimal we didn't even use any solvent
which is really nice
so just another aside too
is over here the instrument this gcms
system that i'm using a single
quadrupole
it does have an auto sampler on it now
spme you saw me doing everything
manually but you can easily
automate spme at with an xy
type z type auto sampler like you see up
here
but today we want i wanted to show you
how to do it manually so when you first
get into the technique you can just buy
a holder and some fibers it's pretty
inexpensive
and try it out work out your method and
then if you want to
go the next step then you can invest in
the auto sampler so
next thing is i'm going to show you when
the run is done i'm going to show you
the hemp compared to a lavender flower
that i did the same technique on earlier
today
all right so earlier today i did this
spme technique on some freshly cut
lavender flowers that i cut from one of
my flower pots at home
and i just put a few of the purple buds
in one of those glass vials and just did
that extraction the same way that you
saw me do it for the hemp
and i wanted to show you what the
terpene profile looked like
compared to the hemp sample that we just
did
so over here on the bottom chromatogram
that is lavender
the top is hemp so you can see that
they're very distinctly very different
mainly this great big peak here this
terpene that's present in the lavender
is not present in the hemp and when i
searched this this was a little little
acetate
which you would expect to find in
lavender because that's a very um
a prominent terpene in that particular
type of fragrance so
this spme technique can be used for
basically telling things apart and
fingerprinting different varieties of
hemp or
and or cannabis being marijuana so you
could use it for that
as far as being quantitative today what
we did was qualitative
but the technique is definitely
quantitative it just involves a little
bit more
work because you have to prepare
standards and extract them with your
spme fiber
but we have plenty of information on
that so please contact any one of our
team members if you're interested in
spme you're learning more about it
like quantitation or fiber choice or
anything like that
so with that i thank you for your
attention and i wish you all a
very good day
welcome to kenner lab my name is rafael
in this talk i will be sharing some tips
and tricks for setting
gcms instrument parameters for terrapins
and cannabis analysis
i hope that you find this information
informative and that with these tips and
tricks
you continue to advance your laboratory
productivity
by reducing unnecessary downtime
the life science business of merck kgaa
barbershop germany operates a smaller
port sigma in the us and canada
let's take a look at the agenda for this
presentation we'll take a look at the
introduction talk about terpenes and
it's testing
we'll take a look at the sample
preparation that's used for this
analysis
we'll discuss the gcms instrument
conditions and then we'll take a look at
the analytical results
let's discuss the workflow for terpenes
analysis
first we perform sample preparation
followed by gcms instrument analysis
which allows us to detect and calibrate
our analytes of interest and achieve
consistent results terpenes are a large
and diverse class of organic compounds
produced by a variety of plants and some
insects
they often have a strong order or aroma
to them
although sometimes used interchangeably
with terpenes
terpenoids or isopronoids
are modified terpenes as they contain
additional functional groups
usually oxygen containing
tape terpenes are hydrocarbons
terpenes are also a major biosynthetic
building block
for example steroids are a derivative
of the triturbine squalene
here are the are the analytes terpenes
and terpenoids
analyzed from cannabis flower which
we'll be discussing throughout this
presentation
let's talk a little bit about the
nomenclature of these analytes
terpenes contain c10 no substitutions
for example caffeine and limonene the
sesquiterpenes are the c15 containing
analytes with that have no substitutions
for example alpha
cedrine and beta carothylene
dyed terpenes those with c20 such as
phytol
is a diet turbinoid since it contains
an o h or hydroxy group
o h hydroxyl ketograph substitutions
make these species
terpenoids let's take a look at the
sample preparation steps
how do you get terpenes analytes in a
vial for analysis
there are many different possible ways
to get analytes extracted prior to
analysis in terms of sample preparation
techniques available to us
analytical chemists there's spme or
solid fixed extra extraction which my
colleague
spoke about their solid liquid
extraction their sketchers
stands quick easy cheap effective rugged
and safe
there's pros and cons to this technique
when applied to cannabis flower
and there's spe or solid phase
extraction
there's also diluting shoot however
that's not a viable option for this
particular matrix
a more important question becomes how do
we get what we want inside the vial
while at the same time minimizing the
components and matrix
that we do not want our selected method
of sample preparation was based on how
do we maximize analyte recovery
what would maximize instrument uptime
what is feasible
and what customers were already doing in
the marketplace
or were willing to try for our
extraction procedure
one gram of cannabis flower which was
finely ground
was weighed in place in a centrifuge
tube
to this we added 10 ml of gc grade
ethyl acetate to each tube and cap
we sonicated for 15 minutes then we
centrifuge the tube
for five minutes and we transfer one mil
of the supernatant
to a two mil autosampler vial and we cap
our working standard solutions were
prepared for
from cannabis chirping standard mix a
and b c certified reference materials
available from millerborough sigma
support
and these were at 2 000 micrograms per
ml
we made dilutions and ethyl acetate
gc grade
and we ensure that these would place an
amber
vials from the working standard solution
with generated calibration
uh standards in the following range
ranging from
0.75 to 100 micrograms per ml
or 0.75 ppm to 100 ppm
let's take a look at the gcms analysis
the gcms instrument conditions please
note that we utilized a 20 meter 0.18.18
slb 5ms column the inlet temperature of
the gc was 300 degrees c
and the flow was kept constant at 0.75
mils per minute of helium
a two microliter pulse split fifty to
one injection was used
it is very important to to note that the
300 degree seat temperature is necessary
on the inlet to ensure
that some of the analytes in our case
phyto
one and two are
readily transfer onto the gas
chromatograph column
and reaches our detector
let's take a look at the extracted iron
chromatogram of the chirping standard
mix
we can see our first analyte alpha
pinene we can see our internal standard
in this case tri
tridekin that loots at about 11 minutes
and it loots right in the middle of the
chromatogram with no particular
interference of the analytes
our last eluding analytes phyto one and
two
required and a high temperature of 300
degrees to ensure
that they the column and into the
detector
let's review the detection and
calibration
in this case we see alpha pinene
we see the levels from 0.75 ppm
to 100 ppm and we see that three replica
injections at 50 micrograms per ml
is very highly reproducible in this case
we use
m sub z 93 for the quant iron and m sub
z
105 and 125 for the qualifiers
please note that you can perform this
analysis in the same
or scan mode however sim will give you
higher sensitivity
however sim will not provide you with
library hit matches so if you want to go
ahead
and search nist or wiley or other
libraries you wouldn't have to perform
full scan analysis
so i would recommend using both the sim
scan approach
that most instrument vendors provide as
an option
here we can see that for alpha pining
the rsds
were 3.52 percent linearity
r square 0.999 in the range
of 0.75 to 100
ppm yellow d at 0.25 ppm and the loq at
0.75
let's take a look at the internal
standard response reproducibility as we
mentioned
tridecane is used as an internal
standard throughout this analysis
and as you can see from the
reproducibility of the retention times
as well as the
reproducibility of the internal standard
response it is very highly reproducible
for injections over a calibration range
this is one of the critical attributes
that you should be
look at when you're developing a gcms
method ensure that you have
extreme relative retention time
reproducibility as well as
response reproducibility in this case
we're taking a look at an overlay of
three sample injections
showing repeatability even with matrix
interferences the method reproducibility
is easily achieved
sample preparation and robust gc inlet
conditions are key
in order to achieve this
note here that the larger sample
components do not interfere with the
quantitation and identification of the
terpene analytes
as you can see cbd connect diol is the
one of the major components here
however it comes off the retention time
is
is not anywhere near our analytes of
interest with the turpin components
elute
here we can take a look at the extracted
compound chromatogram of the hemp sample
as you can see we have tridecane with no
interference right in the middle of the
chromatogram
and we have our alpha pioneer in the
front and our vital one and two
in the back of the chromatogram
phyto one and two would be very
challenging to do via the headspace
gcms technique it's possible
but you you may have you're going to run
into some
issues in terms of using the high
temperature on your vials as well as
your transfer line
for for the headspace analysis
if you perform full scan analysis
during gcms you have the ability to
create a customized mass spec library
which allows for faster analysis time
because you're using a shorter library
as compared to using the completeness
libraries to search
it allows for retention times to be
saved as part of the library
and it facilitates analyte
identification
in this case we're taking a look at the
spectra for alpha humaline
on top we see the nest library spectra
and the bottom we see
the spectrum of our sample and you can
see the high
library match factor of 98.9 for alpha
himalayan
and this allows us to achieve consistent
results having a robust method
a robust method of extraction as well as
a robust method of
instrument parameters in our gcms
systems a lot obtains
results that are very linear very
reproducible
r squares greater than point then three
nines and above
in the range of 0.75 to 100
micrograms per ml and the rsds are
typically lower than 5
in order to achieve this result it
should be noted that sometimes
in order to be in the linear calibration
range of your instruments and avoid
instruments
saturation as well as carry over
you should dilute your samples to to
to low levels i would top it off at
about
250 ppm or use a high split ratio of 50
to 1
or 100 to 1 depending on the the target
levels that you're trying to reach in
your samples
as you can see even for the lady looters
phyto one and two
the r square value is there the range
and the reproducibility is there as well
and our trident as a internal standard
served as a good way to
keep our calibration ranges very linear
over that particular range
in conclusion a fast efficient and
highly reproducible quantitative gcms
analytical method was developed
for the analysis of 31 cannabis related
terpenes
as it can be seen from the illustrations
and results above
utilizing gcms in combination
with supple chromatography consumable
solvent supplies
analytical reagents and certified
reference standards
provides an efficient way to analyze
cannabis products with terpenes
in order to meet the current cannabis
product labeling requirements
reaching low quantitation levels of 0.5
micrograms per gram or 750
ppb is easily achievable and obtaining
all consumables and reagents from one
supplier
ensures that time is spent analyzing and
running samples
rather than finding multiple sources for
your required analytical supplies
keep in mind that utilizing a 20 meter
0.18.18 gc column
provides max maximum chromatographic
resolution of the terpene analytes
and facilitates adding additional
analytes in the future if necessary
here's a product list of the consumables
and supplies and reagents used for this
analysis
and you can find more of this
information in our cannabis landing page
at sigmaaldridge.com cannabis
thank you so much and i look forward to
any questions you may have
you